[Music]
the man behind Beyonce's iconic single
ladies dance and the any Rd and Rihanna
lemon video Jack well night was recently
named one of Forbes 30 under 30 makes
sense because as I found out Jack well
is cooking up something special with
Yonsei for her headlining set at
Coachella let's take it back though to
the very beginning one of your first
gigs was choreographing a little music
video by the name of single ladies I
[Music]
mean come on that I don't think there's
a more iconic dance or choreography than
like Michael Jackson Thriller how's it
feel to know that you're a part of such
like a pop culture phenomenon oh my god
you know single ladies is still a moment
that I have yet to put into words you
know the impact that that piece have had
on culture and you know music and jazz
what it done for Beyonce right you know
it's just mind-blowing you know and just
the impact that it had on people and how
they have how they still kind of turn up
to it and still do the routines and yeah
you know it's something that's gonna
hopefully last forever I'm still doing
it I'm still do it it's like thank you I
mean I walked it I watched a lot of time
so you've worked with Beyonce on the
Super Bowl performances yes formation of
course we know next year her next
high-profile gig will be Coachella yes
be ready for a good time yeah I have a
good old top we're getting ready for
Coachella and you know that's gonna
change the game and super excited what's
one word you can tease to describe her
Coachella performance one word amazing
beyond iconic life like oh thank
[Music]
you